I
hi my name is jeff rose at her ski and i
would be talking about a program called
touch vids today so i was reading a
paper written in the early 2000s called
dustin magnet which involves them on a
computer monitor putting each point of
data like a row in excel as a little
circle and giving you magnets that you
can drag around to pull points based
upon certain values and this was cool
but i didn't think it was all that
tangible you're using a mouse you have a
monitor in front of you it's not
terribly physical on the other hand we
have something like this an ipad which
is physical you can tilt it you can
touch it you can interact with it in new
ways and so i thought why don't we
interact with data using an ipad in
completely different ways tangible ways
so i present to you touch phys which is
an interface for interacting with
multivariate data when I say
multivariate data I mean Rose in an
Excel spreadsheet with a lot of columns
so you see here a bunch of points each
point is in this case a brand of cereal
and a large data set about cereals and I
can do things like I can attract them
based upon certain values so ones that
are higher in protein get pulled to my
finger faster I can filter them so right
now I'm setting anyone with less than
100 calories it's going to pass through
this filter i'm dragging between my
fingers i can then set a wall to keep
them from passing through i tilt iPad
and I can allow them through or not and
finally once you've gotten a set of data
you can then set a histogram which is a
statistical way to see the distribution
of your data so now I want to find it
cereal that are higher or lower in fat
and they automatically self-assemble
into this structure so now you know I
have some that are low in fat and have
few calories i can double click oh look
maybe shredded shredded wheat is a
serial for me that's way cool but this
will let you do even more than that so
i'm going to turn up the gravity push
everything down to the bottom just to
clean up my workspace now i'm going to
draw a histogram of calories this is
going to graph all the points out based
on how many calories they have some
cereals at the top have a lot of
calories like raisins in this one some
don't I can then do a traction to see
all sorts of interesting effects so I
can find out that ones that are high in
fat get pulled to my finger up here more
so than the ones that down here which
are low in calories
so high calories means high fat on the
other hand I can see more interactive
things so the ones that are low in
calorie and high in calorie get put on
my finger when it's dragging on proteins
and so eventually you can dig into your
data and discover all sorts of really
neat features just by doing very
physical things they're real physical
points you're touching dragging moving
around and you're coming up with all
sorts of new discoveries that you'd
never thought you could before because
data is now tangible thank you oh I'm
you and this is John blue and
representing to flight stripes the
awesome app that allows you to explore
domestic flights in United States and
see how delay the war and compare
between airlines destinations and
airports right so oh yeah the FAA
actually makes all this data available
for free so we were able to download it
and the app continues I thing about 3.2
million flights so there's pretty
extensive set of data to work with in
the app so I guess we'll just sort of
launch gonna sort of what it does so app
launches and something kind of an empty
screen here initially but let's um let's
get something on it so let's slaver like
we want to look at from boston to san
francisco and let's just hit graph there
and so it goes to the database and it
quickly in the background so doesn't
block inter interaction draws all those
flights on the screen so this is in this
is a display of flight space on date so
at the top here you can see is january
and to december and the app allows you
to zoom in and really get into the the
data and you can eventually here see
actual flight numbers and sort of hell
delayed they are and if you click on
them you can see more details about the
flight and actually it tells you why it
was delayed in this case it had 62
minutes of its total delay were caused
by an nes delay which means that the
tower i'm basically caused it
because of maybe mild weather or some
situation like that you're you want to
show the comparison how that would work
yeah so let's say you want to fly
between Boston San Francisco and you
want to compare two carriers so what you
can do is first of all you can click on
frame which allows you to see the whole
view again click on sort bike carrier so
now you'll see the flight sorted by
carriers you can see JetBlue continental
United and so on then click on compare
and have a second view that shows you
and you can research and do the same
search for different carrier so let's
say i'm going to do boston to san
francisco again and for the left one
I'll choose jetblue and for the right 1
i'll choose united airlines so a lot
right and graph yeah so engraft bundle
them so and this view you can see that
if I was buying a ticket now I would buy
a ticket from united airlines since they
have much less delays and national
flights on time as you can see in this
view and you can actually zoom in and
both and compare and each one is
independent alright so when thinking
about a place to go to there's a ton of
information out there and about a
million of different ways of getting it
so for our application we're trying to
take all these scattered information
from all over the web and aggregate them
into one immersive experience for the
end goal of just visualizing a place so
let's go right into the demo all right
so say you're going to a place this
place is near Central Park as soon as
you get reach the startup screen you're
presented with a lot of information a
lot of images about the place as well as
text our goal is to get a lot of
dynamically generated content from the
web for example on these images pulled
from Instagram are images of this place
you can kind of get a feel of what the
place looks like as well as you get tips
from foursquare in order to get kind of
what people are saying about it you can
get the number of checking accounts to
see kind of popularity you can as well
as look at like popular words are
demonstrate about this place all this
content is dynamically generated from
the web and as long as you have more
information from these api's you'll keep
display so um on rock can go into more
specific information about
so the idea of an app was to help people
explore places anywhere around the world
the idea is to allow people to let's say
go to New York and find a unique or
exclusive restaurant or a bar even a
cafe hey I found this place that works
it's pretty interesting interesting what
so you can see we just were exploring
around New York and we find this place
it gives us a lot of visuals about what
this place looks like all of our tiles
are really interactive and we can click
on them and like get further information
about the place so for example this one
says beach and if I tap on it it'll
it'll tell me more about why this place
is associated with the word beach and
you can see there are some tips saying
what this what context this word was
used in this provides us a little more
insightful information because this is a
bar and this word says beach so we can
come to know by looking at the images
and things like that that this bar is
located in a sandy beach on the shore of
New York we can also click on all the
other times to get let's say four square
tips tips about the place what people
have to say we even get different you
know times of day pictures and pictures
across seasons even each tile has its
own kind of full view in our
visualization and is able to give us
more information about the place in like
we mentioned everything is dynamically
generated from the web so obviously you
can search for new places so let's just
go to like a different area like we're
just typing in Boston
and it automatically brought us to the
Boston area and you can see all the
different venues that are available here
so let's just like go to a place all
right so this is daniel hall so let's
just go there and it pulled up all these
images so let's say we wanted to know
how this place looked across various
seasons we have the style called a
seasonal view and you can click on the
style and let's say it'll load up you
know images across from different
seasons for us so we have you know
summer winter spring and fall and you
can visualize and see how places look
across different seasons maybe cities
don't change that much but parks or like
places in colder climate have a lot more
snow visually available you can see how
the trees have lights you know during
holiday time episode yes I mean I pretty
much like we just really try to trying
to give people a sense and feel of a
certain place that you really can't get
by going through and looking through
other AP is at least as easily as we try
to give it so like you just go to a
place you just kind of get a good sense
and feel and you just really able to
explore and find out like a lot about
new places around around you yeah we've
aim to kind of give you the people's
perspective rather than you know what
critics have to review about a place and
these are gathered from user submissions
and users having posted information to
these various sources okay so I was
inspired by the a tree map which is a
way of looking at data visually and
getting a feel for how big each one of
the various parts are and so i forked an
old open source project and sort of
modernized it for iOS and what i have is
tree mapper so true mapper takes in a
bunch of data in this case it's a CSV
file and what you're looking at is the
top 100 most visited sites from the
Nielsen group and you can see for
example media / News takes up a
significant portion
of the internet traffic and this entire
thing is built in a scrollview so you
can pan around and look at the various
different portions and you can tap to
drill down and you can see well it makes
up this category in the media news
category you have Fox BBC CBS and you
can just tap to zoom in drill down on
different categories see what makes up
of them and then tap the zoom back out
like this and I've also made it very
general so you can switch between
different data sets so if you swipe here
you are looking at a data set of the
amount of GDP that certain countries
spend on military expenditures so for
example you can see that American
countries tend to spend a lot of their
gdp proportion wise on various military
expenditures and if i were to drill down
to that i can see the USA takes up a big
portion of it tap again to zoom back out
tap on europe it drills down and tap
again so there's two different
interactions there's the pan around
which just looks at whatever the current
level is and then there's the tap which
zooms in or zoom back out depending on
whichever category you're on